but we're kind of going back back to the
original question like we have all these
we have we have a we have a [ __ ] march
for women you've never heard of that
that much like that's so so we complain
about the double standard we have a slot
of like the the body count thing right
like that's a double standard and women
will complain and they'll go they'll
like like men have a higher body count
they don't get they don't get oh yeah
like yeah but women
yeah yeah and so
okay okay but i'm saying like like so
there are marches for that like we have
i don't know if you've heard of this but
there's like a [ __ ] march in california
women will say oh let's own the word and
we'll complain for days about that but
we don't see women marching the streets
for men to pay equal or to you know get
into bars for free or anything else
themselves
women i can't do it
but i'm saying i'm saying like women
women complain about like we want
equality but we only want equality when
it benefits us
like where where's the equality for why
don't women lined up to be plumbers
i feel like we are fighting like as a as
a as a woman yeah we fight for our own
stuff does that make sense so i feel
like if men want it like they should the
equal bar thing they should fight for it
themselves because you know what
especially we live in a world where men
get a lot of more privileges like okay
cool yeah we get into bars and stuff
that's fair enough but there's a lot of
stuff where men are more superior to
women and that's one thing
no no no no no no no just you and what
like jobs like especially
in terms of like jobs i feel like men
get ra men get a lot more respect
okay but it's true it is true though
respect
even in sport okay cool men get a lot of
more like respect in terms of that a lot
more credit a lot more props a lot more
leeway advantages
how is that true when women have
specific grants like there are specific
grants only for women not given to men
on top of that on top of that and there
are quotas so they have to get a certain
amount of women in a job but when a
field is is female-led there's no quota
for men so how so yeah so how is how is
there
how
i feel like women are already fighting a
battle in itself so the money situation
itself like women get paid less to the
dollar to the to the man right but how
do you know how do you know that we're
paid less because we're women i mean
you're the stats ladies because you're
going to have a profession like if
you're going to be an engineer like
there's not a lot we're female in the
only but even when it comes to sports
right the only sport that is paid the
exact same money though no but i'm
saying oh tennis but yeah
that's because respectfully i know
men are better than women at sports
sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry
i'm sorry you're probably you you
specific you're probably better than
most men but in general like most men in
the nba can dunk wnb can't and they and
they get paid more because they make
more money
like that like women's ncaa has been at
a loss for years they don't even make
money
and why is that because because people
don't watch as much because it's just
not as entertaining who's i don't even
keep who runs the show who who's the top
dog the man because every time you know
what you know like no
i swear
i was like if i really want to watch a
women's game like i would watch a
women's game like that when it gets to
like
certain levels like finals semi-finals i
like i was here but like
this is like and i'm a sports person so
like imagine people like that aren't
like it's sad it's sad because listen if
i was a woman i would [ __ ] hate men
i'd be like the feminist like slew them
but it's like it is like it is always
with like on an individual level what
we're going to do is the people
just one second just that fact in itself
what you're saying you know i mean and
that is why there's those women groups
because of these situations it's so hard
for us to get jobs and then you add
race into it you add where you live
ethnicity all these things are so
difficult so yeah there are only women
clubs there are only women gyms oh no
there's nothing because there's dirt
who went in the corner
yeah there's these things all put in for
women because for so many years they've
been
suppressed devalued
like
are how are we devalued we got to stay
at home and not work that [ __ ] sounds
awesome
though yeah she fighting with the school
but but i'm saying like like like even
even the women but that was only that
came from like the war days where the
women had jobs in the war and then the
men came home and then they took those
women's jobs so then they got put back
in the home and now you have to live
well
like historically men had to fight in
war so how can we say we were oppressed
we never had to fight in wars no but i'm
like
they're getting control
and then also
and even let's talk about the pay gap
like the reason that when men are paid
more than women is because they pick
industries that make more money
so like like if you go to the most
egalitarian countries in the world where
women have more choice
the the pay gap is bigger
because
men choose like professions with objects
where women's women choose profession 20
people wait wait shout them out i will
later no but i'm asking like like our
automatic gut reaction is always that
like it's about male and female
but like how do you know it's not just
the industries we pick
no for sure industry lot industry is a
big thing
for you man
now go ahead i've spoken my my part yeah
i agree with her a lot i can't lie um i
feel like there's just a lot of factors
like you can say okay cool like men get
to go work and the women get to stay at
home and it's all fun but it's not all
fun and games a lot of those women are
abused they're treated like crap like
that but why are they controlled but why
is that your immediate like like i just
don't understand why that's your
immediate gut reaction is to say like
they're at home because they're
controlled and they're abused and all
that stuff
like i know what i'm asking is that is
that your your your view on men it's
just that you think the majority of men
are like abusing their women no but i
think a lot of those women are unhappy
and it comes from the old school days
like where they're actually suppressed
and they're kind of taught they're
brought into that tradition and it just
continues where a lot of those women
actually are unhappy and they would like
to speak out and that's
like if your mom raised you like yo
don't chase [ __ ] from no man
like you would move completely different
cultures though different cultures
i'm saying she says all this culture i'm
like but it depends on like who you've
been raised about like some families
invite there's something but that's what
that's where zania was like that's where
race comes into ethnicity a lot of those
things come like they're big factors
like we can all talk about the
positivity but there are other sides
like we're here to have a discussion on
all those different types of views so we
can't just say oh like yeah there's all
those women are happy but not all those
women are happy a lot of those who are
faking that happening
why is that your assumption how do you
know we don't but that is yeah but you
also see it from one
um perspective
in a white world in america so you only
see one way so you don't really see how
the other different ethnicities
different cultures have completely their
women have to stay at home that is
you're saying that's really cool but as
women
we're starting to we want to be ceos we
want to be pushing where we're the equal
of men and this is what she's saying as
a young woman is saying like actually no
i would like to pay i would but do i
have the opportunities to make the same
money or do i have seen it even if it's
all these old schools
but i'm saying like like if that's true
like why in the countries where women
have more choice than ever is the pay
gap bigger so you can you can make a
list of countries right where women are
the most depressed and the least
depressed and the pay gap grows when
women have more choice
because of the industries they pick but
a lot of men so i'm not even talking
about other factors i'm just talking
about like male and female go ahead so a
lot of men do run those industries
though that determine those pays like a
lot of men even that they're very biased
in terms of like even internal
promotions and stuff within companies
but they can't change a pay grade like
of like yo you're a man
but i'm saying to to offset that we have
quotas so there are like i worked in
copier sales for two years that's a very
male dominated industry it's [ __ ] it's
awful
oh my god
and they couldn't get women to stay
because it was terrible like it's a like
those those jobs are working 80 90 hours
a week my dad worked 80 hours a week my
whole life
i do you want i don't want to work 80
hours a week i don't know many girls
that do there's a lot of women that
actually are out there like even in a
lot of countries like they're working a
lot they're working like two free jobs
just to keep it yeah but i'm saying but
i'm saying if that's true then why in
the countries where they have the most
choice to do that do less women well
she's seven like you know where we're
all wealthy
so i'm saying like like you go to the
countries where women have more choice
an opportunity to do those things and
they choose not to why if women want to
i think it's just a lot to do with like
history as well though like you're stuck
in a phase so maybe women i i'm not
saying women don't make there's a lot of
women that make stuff harder for
themselves like we do all have a choice
but there's a lot of circumstances that
dictate that like we can even go back
like i don't know this is relevant but
it actually makes sense to me like the
whole molly may like we all have 24
hours in a day like we actually don't
have the same 24 hours in a day like
everyone's circumstance is actually
different everyone says
there's so many factors that come into
that like like culture like everything
like it's just the opportunities don't
actually get given like as much as you
think they do that's a race thing it's
not like a gender thing for sure like
it's not just it's not just race though
like there's a lot of caucasian women
that face those issues
disability like there's a lot of like
other other factors but i'm saying like
just pure gender are like
but then if you're like you would never
you wouldn't reject a job for like a
woman
over a man because you saw the name if
they had the same skills like
well and the other question is like why
aren't we rallying like we'll talk about
ceo and power positions but why aren't
we talking about women not wanting to be
things like garbage collectors plumbers
like all the hard jobs in the in the
military
like it's always like that's what i'm
saying we only got a little there's a
there's a lot of women in the military
but they get treated like absolute [ __ ]
they don't get paid you know women
though you don't know i don't know any
man
i don't know any women plumbers but i
know a navy person and he they
disrespect women like nothing they treat
them like [ __ ] and he's a high-ranking
person no that's not i don't like it and
so it's hard to be this but then there's
also it's like okay there's not men
beauticians like there's this job
there's just gender jobs that just like
uh we're trying to break off why can't
there be a woman plumber why can't there
be a man who does my eyelashes
there's not enough man be like yo i want
to do eyelashes and then it's like
they're wrong
but this is why like i'm going back to
the same question where it's like we're
complaining about inequality when it
doesn't like benefit us
or when it we complain about inequality
but only like we only complain about the
ones that don't benefit us like we don't
we don't rally the same way i've always
been intrigued to like hear this like
really intriguing like because obviously
you like
for women you're fighting for like
yourself like
and i like i said i'll be the same way
if i was a woman i would hate me
but i'm saying like for the ones that
benefit you
like but are you rallying are you
rallying because you're paying to get
into clubs not everyone's rallying yo
not every girl's right out here rallying
like no but i'm just saying i'm saying
you no are you i don't mind them coming
together like i'm sick of paying a
hundred pounds
it's not about rally it's about sharing
your opinion like oh yo these toys are
going for free like whatever that you
can't say that about guys you can't like
you know what i mean like that's the
thing you're contradicting yourself
there because she she just asked you a
question and said but are you valiant
i'm not going to rally because
women don't get the rights
whatever like but i'm saying like okay
i've done it all by the way
no like those people
no but like say there's a woman like
there's a guy that probably went to that
rally that is just going because his
wife's there
like it's not like they care like it's
just like if it affects you
then you would you would have a reason
like for women's rights like it's very
different because if it affects you then
managing thrown off like their phone
like
object like you know what i mean in the
background like they're going to be like
just think stereotypes you're right
every each gender picks which one
affects them which one they want to care
about which i i mean i've had
relationships where it's really
affecting me i'm like why can you do
this and i can't do this like and i
think maybe in sporting world also like
we're in a very oh i think most women
but we're in a very man like driven in
yeah dominated sports so now though
no and it's like and it is frustrating
i'm sure it's frustrating to you too
like i wish women were paid more in
sports it's ass like i mean you probably
actually make december i know people
don't even like watching women's sport i
don't believe in it right yeah i've had
like a top like top top guy say to me
yeah we just come for the drinks and the
party for the women like you lot are
just our social club big boy i'm talking
like
top top top
level and just said to me not our
country but just said like yeah i just
come for the bench like i just come to
see the women playing and have a drink
with my mates like we don't respect it
and if the top men are talking like that
how do you think it then affects how do
you think it trickles down
you don't think there's a talent
difference in men and women in like like
basketball okay who's the better team
london lions women or men
you know if we played you we're better i
i think we praise you
i think
men and women in like sports personally
basketball because i'm a basketball
player myself and i love watching
basketball i feel like men play with
pride and women play as a team that's
what i think okay so if you're not
allowed if you're not allowed to dunk
if you're not
listen listen listen listen if you're
not allowed to dunk
and we pl we should do this
everybody on that day let's
no no no no you really think you'd be
our team like well not in a full game
what fight like a minute like